kourtney kardashian and travis barker
are engaged i mean it was beautiful
amazing the blink 182 rocker popped the
question on the beach in montecito
california and now a source tells e.t
the pair couldn't be happier about
taking this next step in their
relationship quote courtney and travis
are over the moon getting engaged was
always their natural next step and they
are so thrilled the proposal was
gorgeous and romantic and everything
courtney wanted this is insane the whole
thing went down at the rosewood miramar
beach hotel and according to the source
it's a place that is considered to be
quote very special and sacred to them
quote their families are beyond happy
and excited for them too their kids are
very much looking forward to being an
official big happy family
i love it et source adds that the two
really feel like they found their
perfect partner and match quote they
can't wait for this next step in their
journey as a couple and to spend the
rest of their lives together this is
such a dream come true but back to that
proposal fans filmed travis and court as
they walked down the beach at sunset to
a heart made of red roses lined with
candles and after they celebrated with
an intimate yet lavish dinner with their
closest loved ones
and look closely because that's
definitely a camera crew they're filming
we're thinking that means we'll see all
the sweetness on the family's upcoming
hulu reality show the 42 year old
reality star confirmed the news on
instagram sharing these snaps from the
romantic moment alongside the caption
quote forever travis quickly slid into
the comments echoing her sentiment along
with an infinity symbol emoji
of course the two have been friends and
neighbors for a long time and started
dating in january and since then they've
taken many family trips with their kids
court shares three kiddos
eleven-year-old mason nine-year-old
penelope and six-year-old reign with her
ex scott disick while travis is a dad to
two kids with his ex-wife shayna moekler
18 year olds landon and 15 year old
alabama and the couple well they've
never shied away from a little pda
i love you
[Music]
the rocker even got a tattoo of her name
and court later inked i love you on his
arm
well now they're making their love
permanent so we'll send you off with
that sweet moment on bended knee one
more time
[Music]
you